so
hello everybody my name is hana verbal
and i've been invited to give a
presentation here
on the issue of reproducibility in
animal research
i am a professor of animal welfare at
the university of bern in switzerland
and i'm very happy to be here and to
talk to you
even though it's a bit strange to talk
to my
notebook here not seeing anybody sitting
anywhere
but i hope this is going to be an
entertaining presentation for you all
so i'm going to talk about biological
variation and how that matters for
reproducibility
in the in animal research and of course
reproducibility or
the reproducibility crisis as it is
called has been a big
issue over the last couple of years
and i'm going to particularly focus on
the implications
that has for animal research and
of course if you're talking about poor
reproducibility
then this does not only have scientific
and economic implications
but in the case of animal research it
certainly also has ethical implications
with respect to
the use of animals and as long as we're
not
guaranteeing that the use of animals is
producing any meaningful knowledge
then of course we may risk wasting
animals for inconclusive research
and that is certainly not in the
interest of the population and society
as a general
so the things
or the sources of poor reproducibility
that have been
proposed and these are not limited to
animal research but they also
do matter for animal research are
several
and the most important ones i've listed
on this slide
so there is a lack of scientific rigor
and that is something that has been
revealed by meta research by
meta-analysis looking into papers
and how they report methods and
experimental conduct
and a lot of evidence suggests that in
many cases
studies are not properly randomized
scientists do not use
blinding and do not use other
measures of good research practice that
are meant to
avoid bias and of course if there is a
risk of bias
there's also a risk of poor
reproducibility
then another issue and that is
particularly pertinent to animal
research
is the use of small sample sizes and of
course
usually we do all we can in order to use
as few animals
as possible in order not to
waste animals unnecessarily
but of course if you're not using enough
animals then
this may mean that you lack statistical
power to detect the effect that you're
looking for
and so in the end your results may be
meaningless simply because you have not
used
enough animals then another big issue
is analytical flexibility in many cases
and that is certainly true
for a lot of animal research
studies contain or or include subgroups
of animals
different sexes different age groups
different treatments
and often a number of different outcome
variables are assessed and so there is a
lot of flexibility in statistical
analysis
and of course if you explore the data
and look for statistically significant
associations
and then present these as if they have
been
the result of a rigorously designed
confirmatory study
then you may overblow
your conclusions and you may you may
conclude things from spurious
findings and the final point i want to
mention here is publication bias
or selective reporting in general so if
several outcome measures are assessed
but then only the ones that turn out to
be statistically significant are
published
or whole studies are not published if
they do not
yield statistically significant results
then this is obviously going to distort
the evidence that is published in the
literature and so we cannot rely on
what has been published if a lot of
a lot of results that did not show up as
statistically significant
have simply been put under the carpet
now i'm not going to talk about
these things any further but instead
what i'm going to focus on
is the issue of rigorous standardization
and this is something that is not
usually considered as
a source of poor reproducibility but i'm
trying to convince you in the course of
this presentation
that this is actually a major issue in
animal research
now first look let's look into what
rigorous standardization means
standardization essentially means the
defining of the characteristics of the
animals in their environment
and to keep these characteristics
constant
and of course this leads to a
homogeneous
study sample that is studied under
rigorously controlled and standardized
conditions
and the important point i want to make
here is that
if we compare it to the other sources of
poor reproducibility
they are all considered to be bad
practice they are actually violations of
good research practice
but in terms of rigorous standardization
this is actually something
that is considered as good practice
and many textbooks of labor to animal
science
they actually recommend
to use rigorous and the intention behind
this
is of course to get results that are as
precise as possible
and by reducing the variation in the
results
to be able to use fewer animals for the
same study
now if we want to understand
why this could potentially be a problem
for reproducibility
we first need to go back in history by
about 350 years
to the birth of reproducibility as a
scientific principle to establish
matters of fact back in the 17th century
the royal society at some point decided
that in order to distinguish between
anecdotes reported by
scientists and robust scientific
evidence that they need
some kind of quality control and the
measure that they took
in order to do this was that they
required from then
on that in order for a result to be
accepted as scientific evidence
it needed to be replicated by an
independent
laboratory so at that time
in order to for a result to be accepted
as scientific evidence
it was not sufficient to just publish a
single observation or a single study
but the study had to be replicated
independently
by an independent scientist
now of course since that time we've come
a long way
and these days as you all know we don't
need to
plan multi-laboratory studies or
independent replications in order to get
funding
and we don't need to report independent
replications in order to get our results
published
instead what we're doing is instead of
just observing one animals
we build replicates into our
study design so the picture here
illustrates
uh animals waiting for a study and
instead of just absorb
observing one animal or one cage of
animals
we have a sample size a sample of
animals that we're studying and these
animals are
counting as independent replicates
within
our study design now the problem with
this
is of course that the animals within
such a study population they are a lot
less
independent of each other than an
independent observation in an
independent laboratory
by independent scientists and in
particular
if we come back to the rigorous
standardization that is happening in
laboratory animal science
these animals are usually identical
usually genetically identical they may
be inbred strains or even clones
they have the same age they have been
fed the same food they are housed under
the same conditions
and they are cared for by the same care
stuff and in the end tested
by the same experimenter so they have
lots
of factors that shape their phenotype in
common
and of course the more these conditions
are standardized within the laboratory
the more they risk to be different
from the conditions in a different
laboratory
and the first time that this
got actually the attention
of scientists or in the scientific
community
was a paper published in 1999
by three behavioral geneticists who got
together
to test um different inbred strains of
mice
uh the eight uh strains that are listed
here on this
on this figure and compared them in a
number of different behavioral tests
as is usually done when new mutants
are behaviorally characterized
or when these animals are used in order
to screen
for the effects of new drugs or new
mutations
so as you can see in this picture um
across the three laboratories i've
highlighted
two strains in color and as you can see
uh on this particular outcome measure
an outcome measure of a conventional
anxiety test the elevated plasmas test
you can see that the difference between
these two strains
in albany goes in one direction
in portland it goes in the opposite
direction and in
edmonton there is no difference at all
between these two
strains of mice so
i've put the term despite here in
inverted commas so
poor reproducibility despite rigorous
standardization meaning that people were
discussing well how could this happen
how can results be so
different if because these scientists
they tried
to do as much as was possible to
standardize
the conditions not just the test
conditions but also the housing
conditions
of these animals across the three
laboratories and yet
they sometimes found completely
different results
uh between different strains there were
other cases
um if you look at it on at the two
strains here on the very left you can
see that
there is a little bit of variation
between the different laps
but in general the difference between
the two strains goes in the same
direction
in all three labs and there is a big
difference between these two strains
across
all three laboratories now the problem
is
that in order to know whether you have
such a robust
strain difference or a difference that
may be spurious and may be
limited to the specific conditions of
your own laboratory
in order to know that you need to vary
conditions
it doesn't mean that you need to do a
multi-laboratory study as here
but at least you need to introduce some
variation
in your study design in order to assess
whether a difference is a robust effect
or is very specific to the specific
standardized conditions
that were used in in that experiment
and this is what i have referred to as
the standardization fallacy
namely the attempt to increase
reproducibility
at the expense of external validity
and this is actually what happens when
conditions are standardized within study
that is that there are of course
many factors that can be standardized
across laboratories
housing conditions food the type of
animal being used
but there are also many factors that
simply cannot be standardized
the microbial biome of these animals
will be
laboratory specific the personnel
interacting with the animals cannot be
standardized and so there will be many
environmental factors that cannot be
standardized but will still
affect the animals in one way or another
and therefore
produce different phenotypes between
different laboratories and of course the
more you standardize the more rigorously
you standardize the conditions within
your study
the more the higher the risk that the
results that you will obtain
will be limited or the validity of these
results will be limited to these
specific conditions
now i was by no means the first to
mention this
and if we go back in history a little
bit you can see that ronald fisher
one of the godfathers of experimental
design and statistics
mentioned this already back in the 30s
of the last century
namely that standardization weakens
rather than strengthens our ground for
inferring a result
and this is because a standardized
experiment can supply
direct information only in respect to
the narrow range of conditions achieved
by standardization
so standardization reduces the inference
space
the space to which we can draw
inferences from the results that we have
obtained
and then of course as is normally the
case when experiments get replicated in
a different lab by independent
scientists the conditions are different
and therefore
if the results aren't robust they will
not be
reproducible
and it is important when we're talking
about animal research to understand
that the variation in our studies are
not just random noise they're not just
measurement error but there is a lot of
biological variation biological
variation is the very essence
of all living organisms so animals
differ
by their genes we know different strains
of mice they have different
characteristics
they differ by sex they differ
depending on which environment they have
been brought up in
so early experience the rearing
conditions
weaning age all that can have a strong
effect on the phenotype of the animals
and the same applies to housing and
husbandry conditions and of course
also the test conditions under which
conditions the animals are tested
will affect the outcome of a study
so what we're talking about here is gene
by environment interactions and of
course
every animal is the product of
the interaction between its genes and
its environmental history
and this leads us to the reproducibility
paradox and i've drawn a simple sketch
here
uh taken from a paper that we've
published a couple of years back
where we try to put
the reproducibility of animal research
into perspective
with biological variation
so what i've drawn here is a so-called
norm of reaction
a change in the reaction of the animals
to a particular stimulus
in response to a particular
environmental parameter
parameter this parameter x can be
temperature
it can be noise it can also be a
treatment as it that is applied
to the animals and and as you can see on
the left side by the distribution of the
trade values
depending on um which
level of the environment parameter i
select i may get
different results now we can translate
this
into replicate study so one lab does a
study
under its own specific standardized
conditions
and obtains a result maybe the dark blue
result and then a different lab tries to
replicate
this study but because the conditions in
that lab are different
they will find a slightly different
result here represented by light blue
so this led us to suggest
that if we want to obtain robust results
that are actually generalizable
across the conditions by which
laboratories vary
and therefore reproducible we need to
take this variation as it exists between
laboratories into account
and so we predicted that if instead of a
single laboratory study under highly
standardized conditions
we would conduct a multi-laboratory
condition that
includes or incorporates all this
variation between laboratories
we would obtain a less precise results
as represented by the wider distribution
of this blue distribution here
but the results should be
more consistent and therefore better
reproducible
across different laboratories
and in order to study this we were using
real data
and this is an example of the data that
we use this
is data of 222 studies on the effect of
hypothermia
on the infarct volume in animal models
of stroke
now you may wonder why was this
experiment conducted 220 times
of course it was not all independent
experiments but because hypothermia
is one of the very few treatments that
are also effective in the clinical
population
against stroke or show an improvement in
the outcome of stroke
hypothermia is used as a positive
control
in many many animal studies of stroke
so we had a lot of data to play with and
they are ranked here
along the effect size that they produced
the gray bar indicates that on average
hypothermia reduces
um the infarct volume
of of a stroke by about
50 so what we did with these data we
selected
50 of these 222 studies
um we select the 50 studies that were
most independent of each other meaning
that they came from different labs and
from different scientists
we then used the parameter estimates as
they were reported in the papers
the mean and the standard deviation in
order to generate
sample values and with these data we
then run simulations
with different sample sizes in some
cases
we use sample sizes of 12 in others
24 or 48 animals per group
samples were taken proportionally from
either one
two three or four studies in order to
mimic
single lab studies and also multi-lab
studies including two
three or four laboratories now i'm going
to show you this
in an example here so here you can see
the the design for a single laboratory
study and for a multi-laboratory study
the multi-laboratory studies includes
three laboratories
so in order to generate a
multi-laboratory study we randomly
picked
three papers from the stack of 50
studies
and then took the data as they were
described in these
papers and then proportionally sampled
from these
three different papers in order to
generate
a multi-lab study comprising in this
case
24 animals so 12 each per
treatment group control and treatment
and compared this to a single laboratory
study
in which case we randomly selected one
study
and then sampled all 24 animals from
this particular
single study
so here are results these are
15 studies of
single lab study simulation so this is
15
independent studies taken from these 50
studies
and then data sampled from
the distribution as described in these
papers and as you can see the results
vary quite considerably
across these 15 studies the red line
is the null line so meaning that there
is no effect of hypothermia
and as you can see 50 or 100 the full
spectrum
and even negative results are
represented in this sample of 15 studies
within this selection of 50 studies that
we looked at
the dotted line is the summary effect
size across all 50 studies so that is
the
roughly 50 percent reduction in infarct
volume
that you get when you do a meta-analysis
across all 50 studies
we then looked for the proportion of
studies that found a significant
effect and an effect that accurately
represents that summary effect
and by significant we mean that the
confidence interval doesn't overlap with
the zero line
and with accurate we mean that the
confidence interval of the study
overlaps
with the summary effect size so as you
can see
from these 50 single lab studies there
were only three
that yielded significant and accurate
effect size estimates now when we
when we look at multi-lab simulations
you can see that already with
simulations based on only two studies
we get much more consistent results and
this
improves even further when we take four
laps into account so when we simulate
the study across four
different laboratories as you can see on
the right side of this slide
the number of results that are
significant
and accurate estimates of the overall
effect size
increases from 3 to 10 out of the 15
when we include two laps or two studies
into
into the simulation and if we include
four laps
then on average we get 14 out of 15
of these multi-lab studies producing
significant and accurate effect size
estimates
and it is important to note that these
multi-lab studies
they include exactly the same number of
data points as the single lab studies so
it's not a matter of sample size
it's simply a matter of um sampling
across a wider distribution of data
as it occurs when experiments are
conducted across multiple labs
we replicated this analysis for 13
different interventions in animal models
of stroke
myocardial infarction and breast cancer
and in all cases except for very small
sample sizes in a few cases
we can see a similar pattern of
improvement
of the reproducibility or the
consistency of the results
with an increasing number of
laboratories included
in the multi-lab study so whereas
in most cases single lab studies
produced significant and and accurate
effect size estimates of in less than 50
percent of the cases
this number increased to um
60 to 80 percent in in
multi-lab studies including three or
four laboratories
now one of the reasons that may explain
this effect is the
heterogeneity that exists between
studies study heterogeneity here
represented as i
square over the 13
different data sets that we analyzed
represents the proportion of variation
that is accounted for
by the laboratory or by the study rather
than the treatment effect that was
studied
and as you can see is that the the
large proportion and in in some cases
almost a hundred percent and in one case
even a hundred percent of the variation
in the data was accounted for by
differences
between studies rather than differences
uh
within studies so differences between
animals within studies
and this is a huge heterogeneity which
of course can be explained by the high
degree of standardization within studies
and a much lower degree of
standardization between
studies and when we compare this
with human clinical trials you can see
that this is a completely different
pattern
even though there are in human clinical
trials there are
studies where you find large
heterogeneities of 60 to 100
the proportion of studies in which you
find much lower values of heterogeneity
is much higher in clinical trials
and we believe that one of the most
important reasons for this
is that of course the human clinical
population
is much more variable in each of the
studies
and is much less standardized within
studies compared to different studies
and therefore
these clinical trials they cover a much
larger proportion of the variation that
is that exists across different studies
compared to animal studies where we
usually have a very narrow
space a very narrow inference space
within studies
and differences between studies this is
also shown
um by a recent study where um
scientists interested in the metabolic
rate and the response to obesity and
laboratory mice were analyzing
a big data set across many different
laboratories
they included nearly 10 000 black six
mice so
all mice inbred mice have the same
strain
but what they found was that institution
so the laboratory where the study was
conducted
had the strongest effect on the
variation in the data
so again an indication that
differences between laboratories can be
massive
and may dominate the results of animal
experiments and if we don't take this
into account
we may produce very precise but rather
spurious findings that do not generalize
even across the conditions
that exist between different
laboratories
so to sum this up we
need to be clear that standardized
single lab studies
produce highly unreal unreliable results
because they usually
uh have a poor external validity due to
the fact
that the inference base is reduced by
uh the high degree of standardization
and that therefore standardization can
be an important
cause of poor reproducibility and what
we propose is that instead of
standardizing study populations
we should actively heterogenize study
populations
in order to improve the reproducibility
and this can be done without a need for
more animals
if we use advanced statistical designs
advanced experimental designs and
statistical methods
so eliminating biological variation
through standardization
is a highly inefficient strategy for
generating scientific evidence because
it means
that each specific genotype by
environment interaction will be
studied in a separate experiment and
this is akin to the atomization of
animal research
and as such each of those very specific
studies will contribute very little
to our information gain
so what are the solutions uh possible
solutions
of course we can go back as
proposed by the royal society in the
17th century
and do an independent replication
this can be a useful strategy
but of course even though it is a simple
strategy it
is a rather inefficient strategy if we
think that
every single experiment would have to be
replicated independent
uh in a different laboratory by other
scientists
and there are certainly better um
solutions to this
one solution is multi-laboratory studies
as i've just shown you
multi-laboratory studies are effective
but they are logistically highly
demanding
it needs a lot of organization in order
to bring different laboratories together
and organize the study in a way that the
conditions
can be compared across laboratories and
so this is something that you don't want
to do for every single experiment but
maybe a solution for a late stage
pre-clinical study
before you decide to go into a clinical
trial perhaps
then another possibility is simply to
adjust
the metrics of significance or the
metrics that you apply in order to
decide whether or not your treatment had
an effect
and this is something that can be
applied to research areas that have
highly harmonized methods
as for example the phenotyping of mouse
mutants
where a lot of independent laboratories
are doing similar types of studies using
similar types of tests
and similar animals and in these cases
it is possible to
simply adjust the p-values of single lab
studies in a way
that takes um the random effect
of labs into account so if you have a
good estimate of
how to what extent results vary across
laboratories
you can take this into account
statistically and just
and adjust your single lab results by
this factor
and finally and that's this is the
method that we are working on most
is uh instead of heterogenizing instead
of standardizing study
uh populations to actively heterogenize
them
in single lab studies so instead of
running a multi-lab study
to mimic a multi-lab study by
producing sub-cohorts within a single
study population a sub-cohort of animals
this can be different strains of animals
that are included or it can be different
housing conditions or different test
conditions that are included in a study
design
here is an illustration heterogenization
of study samples in single lab studies
can either be done by varying
systematically varying environmental
factors
factors of housing conditions husbandry
protocols or test conditions
or by variation of genetic factors
so varying the species to strain or the
sex of the animals
and randomized block designs are the
perfect
design that can be used for this and in
many
animal experiments a blocking design
is appropriate anyway because for
example
several animals are housed in a cage and
if you want to account for
the um the dependence of animals that
are housed within a cage
you would include cage as a blocking
factor in this
in the statistical design anyway now
once you do this
and you have a blocking factor in your
study design there is no reason why you
should not make these blocks more
different between each other
and instead of having all the same
animals in all cages
you may have one strain in one cage and
a different strain in another cage
and some of the animals may be exposed
to more stressful conditions and other
animals may be exposed to less stressful
conditions
and by this you create the range of
genetic and environmental variation
that may or should mimic the variation
that normally exists between
different laboratories and through this
get
results that may be less precise but
will be more robust and have a
higher likelihood to produce
reproducible results
than rigorously standardized study
samples
so with this i would like to thank
here some of my collaborators who
contributed to the data that i've shown
here
in particular bernhard felkel who
contributed a lot both
empirically as well as theoretically and
then
my former phd students lucille fought
and helena richter
and my long-standing collaborator joseph
garner from stanford
and other collaborators that have
contributed to this work in particular
johaf benjamini and nirikafkafi from tel
aviv
and emily sena from edinburgh and on the
right side you see
all the institutions that have supported
me
and my team with funding for this
research
thank you very much uh for your
attention
and of course i'm ready to answer
questions
we cannot have a live chat here but
you're welcome to address your questions
via email and i'll do my best to answer
all of them
as quickly as possible
all righty great job that is a wrap so
we're all set
and pretty much from here i'll just do
some quick editing on the
front and back ends just to get it all
ready for the
event yep
all right um can i do this
i mean can i can i see this um once
you've
you've done it or how do you proceed
with this
definitely after i'm done editing i can
send you a
preview link and you can take a look at
your presentation
using that preview link okay so i can
definitely send that over to you once
it's ready
and then we can go from there with any
feedback you might have
okay thank you very much all righty any
other
questions for me before we wrap up here
watch
oh no no you were totally fine yeah that
was great
yeah awesome well that is
everything do you have any other
questions for me before we wrap up
no that's fine sounds good we'll have a
good rest of your day
and i will talk to you soon okay thank
you very much
bye-bye